allora una vita
tra le nuvole effettivamente scusate
anche ho difficoltà a perfetto ok
ecco questo sono io diciamo nella mia
situazione normale di fumettista
diciamo che tutto l'arco parlamentare
del fumetto più o meno l'ho frequentato
quindi la tira molla che magari voi i
più giovani non lo ricorderanno me è
stato un personaggio italiano abbastanza
conosciuto una sorta di elastico vivente
che poi dopo avuto anche una serie di
memorie ecologiste insomma negli ultimi
anni in cui è stato pubblicato fino ad
arrivare a una serie di operazioni
svolte in all'estero diciamo che
dall'inizio ha dato grande soddisfazione
mio padre insomma quindi il primo al
primo pensiero diciamo è stato disney
anche a mia madre e naturalmente
diciamo che sono nato in un periodo in
cui il fumetto aveva come tipo di
interfaccia unicamente le piccola ne
parlò anche dopo per quei da subito
insomma avuto questa passione il mio
punto di riferimento era appunto il
l'edicola dove si acquista per giornale
l'unico luogo dove era possibile
interagire in qualche modo con il
fumetto stesso cominciai a disegnare
naturalmente era una passione
irrefrenabile quindi vivevo di matite di
colori e tutto il resto
con risultati a volte discutibili come
tutti quelli che pensano ad altro
rispetto alla proprietà
diciamo che propriamente non era non
solo una persona più adatta a fare i
giochi che normalmente i ragazzi fanno
questa età e poi aveva una serie di come
dire di domande esistenziali insomma
cioè la domanda fondamentale era cioè
come file isner scrive tutte quelle
storie ogni settimana insomma poi dopo
l'ho scoperto
e mentre lei quella era un'epoca sto
parlando degli anni 70 80 in cui non
esistevano insomma tutti comicdom
attualmente festival esposizioni e cioè
del certo come oggi quindi
effettivamente l'unico luogo
ripeto ritorno a questo dove era
possibile interagire col fumetto
trovarlo vedere quello che era stato
obbligato le novità era appunto le di
vela per cui per me ogni volta che ogni
settimana rimasto poi settimanale
topolino
per me era un evento e questo
naturalmente era il mio preferito
questo è uno di quelle persone che in
qualche modo mi ha formato floyd
gottfredson è stato il primo grande
disegnatore di topolino quello che ha
creato all'esterno e più belle punto il
mistero di macchianera insomma tutti i
meccanismi narrativi tipici del mistery
a fumetti li trovavamo appunto in questo
grande autore che è stato uno dei vari
interpreti appunto del topolino disney
ha poi naturalmente quel mostro sacro
cioè carl barks quello che l'uomo dei
paperi e in particolare questo
bellissimo volume della mondadori mi
ricordo dove sono le storie più belle
appunto di di zio paperone
naturalmente non era soltanto disney
c'erano anche altre giornali appunto di
boyle mephisto di tex come fisso tutte
le storie di magia mi hanno influenzato
tantissimo zio tibia dove praticamente
sono delle piccole storie horror di
origini americane mi colpivano
moltissimo poi la moria insomma dicevamo
è stato naturalmente gli ha colti l'uomo
dei salami per morire ecco qua grande
guitto grandissimo uno degli autori più
prolifici tra l'alto più particolari
immaginate che per esempio con un manto
pea europea uno di quelle strutture
linguistiche del fumetto tipiche appunto
è lui è stato l'unico mentre noi ne
prendiamo normalmente in america quindi
band march poco eccetera eccetera
lui era in grado invece di fare uno
schiaffo per esprimere non adoperare lo
schiaffo quindi tutta all'italiana
e poi naturalmente il disney italiane
perché sapete insomma l'italia creare
cioè ha dato i natali ha dei grandissimi
disneyani autori disney particolare le
lenticchie tra salami effettivamente
insomma
potrebbe anche venir fame dicevamo lenti
che bambino è stata una delle più belle
di questo signore qua romano scarpa
grandissimo autore disneyano scomparso
da un po di tempo a quello che ha creato
tutte le storie che mi hanno fatto
sognare quando appunto io andavo in
edicola andrò a prendere topolino e che
poi mi hanno portato a desiderare di
entrare in quel mondo
ecco queste sono alcune delle storie
siano dei meccanismi narrativi perfetti
l'india di cali l'uomo di alta erano
anche delle prese in giro di film famosi
insomma come l'uomo di alcatraz e in
particolare appunto lenticchie di
babilonia che mi ricordo che c'era anche
una nota attualmente il come dire tra
virgolette vietata all'interno della
disney di sorta di malinconia si vede
uno zio paperone con la barba perché ha
perso tutti i dollari eccetera eccetera
e massara insomma particolare come tipo
di struttura e poi questo signore avuto
anche il piacere di conoscere uno dei
più grandi autori disneyani
sceneggiatore questa volta carlo chendi
autore di bellissime storie di nocciola
che la conosceva strega e dei suoi alter
alter che un pippo quale personaggio
particolare secondo un trader levin
soprattutto l'assessore veramente matte
assolutamente matte poi abbiamo
quest'altro signore luciano bottaro noi
più grandi dei formatori disneyani
c'erano in grado di deformare i
personaggi e quindi uno dei primi
innovatori assieme a quest'altro questo
è stato giorgio cavazzano è stato degli
autori che maggiormente mi ha
influenzato in quegli anni per che per
primo ha cominciato a dare un dinamismo
al segno disneyano molto molto forte che
poi avrebbe poi portato a una classicità
diciamo nel segno stesso diciamo che se
avevo tutto della disney tutto cosa che
parlando a volte con i ragazzi più
giovani e non
ma mi sento arrivano al primo grado di
parentela insomma ma sapevo tutto della
della disney assolutamente tornare un po
la storia ecco come dire verificata una
sorta di strana congiunzione astrale per
cui assieme a degli amici
ecco questa è una sorta di schema tutti
i pallini che vedete sono tutte persone
appassionate come me di fumetto anche
bravi nel disegno che poi sarebbero
diventati dei professionali i
professionisti sudare
immaginate quanti nel giro di tre la
zona zona insomma abbastanza vicina alla
nostra città quanti per su quante
persone c'erano che facevano che uno
stesso tipo di passione tra questi prono
brindisi luigi coppola siniscalchi de
angelis e cioè tutti quei piccinino
tutti quelli che attualmente formano
quella che la bonelli almeno settore del
sud quindi da dylan dog e tex eccetera
eccetera
all'epoca che facemmo avuto dal salmo e
per la prima volta creammo visto che
nessuno ci voleva per pubblicare visto
che i rapporti erano solo di edicola
decideremo di fare una nuova rivista e
creiamo questo strano oggetto che è una
franzino sapete davanti non altro un
giornalaccio normalmente ciclostilato in
quel caso lì lo prima colori senza
sottotitolo insomma fatto sta che grazie
a questo è una serie di altri numeri
successivi tra l'altro ereditati da un
gruppo di ragazzi che attualmente sta
lavorando attorno a un nuovo truman
nutrono scusatemi e di fatto però grazie
a questo tipo di vetrina riuscimmo a
cominciare a partecipare ai primi alle
prime esposizioni appunto che si davano
al fumetto
diciamo che io nel frattempo dovevo
laurearmi quindi non è che proprio fosse
visto il mio mestiere come il miglior
ero costretto quasi a farlo di nascosto
cominciare comunque a farlo naturalmente
all'inizio non è che vada proprio
benissimo che sono le tipiche risposte
che si hanno gli sfruttatori
naturalmente comunque riuscito a
laurearmi in architettura gentilmente
hanno detto appunto dovrei essere
architetto ma sono un'anomalia in questo
senso
naturalmente portai
un'architettura la passione rimase per
cui diciamo che quello che facevo avrà
sempre molto a che vedere con il fumetto
diventare un gol spense il gos pencil
diciamo che con il quale disegna ma
senza che il suo nome compaia sul
fumetto ecco disegnato quindi prestato
la mia metti le matite a disegnatori
insomma più conosciuti che però erano
amici per cui da me piacevano fare come
dire fare un po le ossa
fino a che appunto abbey la prima
chiamata quindi ed il presunto piacere e
cominciai a disegnare le prime cose vi
sono alcune delle prime tavole
realizzate della mia prima storia
nonostante siamo tutti avesse scritto in
questo libro avesse sdoganato il fumetto
come linguaggio importante quindi
accanto a linguaggi più più antichi più
consolidati diciamo che la reazione del
pubblico era sempre la scienza insomma
per cui classico oppure o ancora ecco
per esempio la confusione dal cartone
animato il fumetto
le idee non mai mai troppo chiaro in
questo senso seconda chiamata prezzemolo
ancora un elemento di cucina attualmente
era il draghetto di gardaland chiamata
fu da parte sua e cominciano diciamo il
lavoro professionistico
diciamo che prendevano stato un
apparenza nel senso che per la prima
volta un nutrito gruppo di disegnatori
molti disneyani diede vita a un
personaggio il tutto italiano però con
anche un forte appeal soprattutto mondo
alle spalle insomma diciamo che è stata
un'esperienza decennale poi purtroppo si
è spenta con sodo per mancanza di
finanziamenti per cambiamenti politici
all'interno di gardaland è stata la cosa
abbastanza interessante chiudere alcune
delle tappe queste sono le le chine
naturalmente prima della pubblicazione
poi scriviamo un altro top o poi
arriveremo al topo più e reggio più
conosciuto e quindi passai a quest altro
personaggio diciamo più pupazzetti stico
che altro che però devono un suo pandant
fumettistico per un certo periodo avuto
ancora
non certo un certo successo vi sono
alcune le copertine che ho realizzato
è un personaggio diciamo il target era
abbastanza per piccoli questo signore
penso procede tutto il direttore a lui
devo devo dire grazie a questo
personaggio un certo periodo ho lavorato
per la mascotte diciamo non è molto
conosciuta perché non si è scelto di non
utilizzarla molto però all'inizio ci
voleva puntare molto su questo piccolo
personaggio sulla questo piccolo grifone
griffi però grazie a lui ea la tonda di
giffoni
ho avuto modo di conoscere questa
signora il signor è la prima dice niente
magari però è la prima direttrice di
topolino minni e stato un cambiamento
epocale da maria gentilini e grandissimi
direttori ha spostato troppo grandi
direttori di giornale la prima donna
attualmente c'è un'altra direttrice
ancora quindi diciamo la sequenza
continua valentina de poli clarita muci
ho avuto la possibilità quindi grazie
alle 9 alle nocciole e sa come tosi di
conoscere questa direttrice quindi
finalmente arrivai a quello che era la
mia passione ha chiamata per fare questo
vivendo qui a salerno affrontai per
assicuro è stata una cosa abbastanza
tosta e l'espresso salerno milano per
potere lavorando già quindi per poter
essere lì ogni mattina un giorno sì e un
giorno no si trovava di tutto non so se
avete presente il bar di guerre stellari
primi primo guerre stellari qualcosa del
tipo ma abbastanza pericoloso che è
stato soppresso e arrivare finalmente
nell'androne di via sandro sandri della
pista in tram per me fu queste non c'è
attualmente queste norme topolino in
legno con il bancone insomma il suo
ricordo indelebile pro die all'accademia
di sneaker un'appendice della disney per
cominciare a lavorare con loro e grazie
a questo è stato il mio primo mezzo al
santos issimo dei migliori sceneggiatori
disneyani cominciai naturalmente
abbastanza particolare insomma lavorare
all'interno del senso ci sono tutta una
serie di cose di patti di segretezza da
mantenere cosi anche stranissime
presente non si può dire pippo è dio
perché perché ogni retaggio di tipo
religioso è assolutamente vietato quindi
vabbè poi ho qui ho avuto modo di
conoscere un amico o nemico baku cui è
insomma abbiamo condiviso la passione
perché al barks e quindi in genere per
disney e dopo una serie di rifiuti dei
primi soggetti presentati alla fine mi
dietro il via e quindi da allora ha
cominciato a collaborare
queste sono alcune delle storie
realizzate tra l'altro anche per
disegnatori abbastanza bra molto molto
bravi quindi diciamo da paperino
topolino gamma di lenza un po tutti
quanti personaggi più altri progetti
particolari come può essere un progetto
e poi non è andato in porto però è
interessante perché era una sorta di
ritorno agli anni cinquanta disneyano in
cui all'interno di una sorta di junior
di college paperone molto giovane è un
archimede molto giorni un picco dei
padri che insegna insomma tutta una cosa
particolare è da notare anche il papero
il papero di colore insomma c'era questa
idea di tirare questa sorta di padre ho
chiamato sacher sacher duck
tutto questo mi ha portato naturalmente
a riflettere anche sul linguaggio del
fumetto in tutti questi anni per esempio
a questa che vedere una vetrata se avete
presente le vetrate delle delle chiese
quello che grazie anche a scott mcloud
stato uno dei principali come dire
studiosi di fumetto scritto un
bellissimo libro understanding comics
che ha fondato proprio linguaggio a
becco riuscito a capire esattamente come
il linguaggio da quali meccanismi fosse
composto e a proposito della vetrata ha
notato questo che fondamentale
all'interno del fumetto quello spazio
non tanto quello che c'è nelle vignette
mano spesso che c'è tra le vignette in
b2 il cosiddetto in between o spazio
bianco clos sur e prendendo il
linguaggio delle vetrate cioè
praticamente giusto per
a dirlo in parole povere queste sono due
vignette là in mezzo c'è uno spazio
bianco andiamo a guardare da vicino che
succede ecco guardate che cosa c'è torna
un attimo indietro c'è un vampiro né e
c'è poi un urlo
quindi sono un sacco di spazio di tempo
la mente
noi andremo a riempire quello spazio
bianco per cui come vedete
nell'interstizio ci sarà tutta una serie
di successive mentre sta questa questa
cosa qui mi ha affascinato mi ha colpito
è praticamente mi ha fatto capire che
all'interno del fumetto è ovvio ci sia
una parte letteraria molto molto forte
preponderante naturalmente anche una
parte grafica in genere sono due
categorie che non proprio si possono
vedere diciamo e e quindi cominciamo
grazie anche all'arrivo di un altro
amico con il cui praticamente decidemmo
di approdare in francia dove c'è una
possibilità di muoversi anche
all'interno dei canali di strutture
diverse da quella dal mondo disneyano
che era abbastanza
come vede questo rigido e fermo a
particolare regole in francia abbiamo
realizzato una serie matt dedicata una
sorta di ritorno alla campagna
napoleonica quindi sono una serie di
personaggi insomma una sorta di fantasy
sono alcune delle tavole se sono le
tavole prima della della pubblicazione
naturalmente e poi abbiamo creato
quest'altra quest altra storia
pandamonio un mondo dominato da mutanti
adesso ci porta molto però all'epoca
prima cosa abbastanza nuova dalla retta
dalla duxford line up in una casa
editrice abbastanza importante queste
sono alcune delle tavole ma anche dei
modellini sono stati realizzati e poi
charlotte non sarà un po per adulti
diciamo se volete bene operare una sorta
di noir molto molto divertente poi ho
avuto modo di conoscere altre persone
come quest altro amico antonio scarpetta
comunque abbiamo realizzato una serie d
non solo imboccata abbiamo iniziato a
sperimentare un po l'utilizzo del storie
potesse essere appunto interattiva in
particolare lo sri bucap che una
tipologia di libro interattivo non molto
diffusa almeno in italia ma nei paesi
anglosassoni moltissimo gli abbiamo
vinto il terzo posto come migliore
storybook non trova soddisfazione di
arrivare prima della della disney che
aveva presentato a sua volta uno storico
e un fatto cielo trento e questo bambino
che con le ombre gioca crea una serie di
effetti toccando lo schermo era
possibile poi muovere le mani e quindi
fargli fare le ombre cioè vi sono alcune
delle illustrazioni target diverso che
ho realizzato delle altre opere questo
bambino sempre al telefonino che però
lavora nel circo quindi rete del circo
rete appunto dell'internet poi abbiamo
lavorato per poi all'interno di comics
per nino napoletano ad effetto
l'antologia di tutti i disegnatori della
campania per un'unica storia e poi
abbiamo bruciato sperimentare un po di
linguaggi è una specie di riedizione di
acab quest'altro è una ricorrendo il
trecentenario della della nascita di
giovan battista piranesi in un libro
illustrato appunto sulla sua vita e poi
tutta una serie di altre illustrazioni
modo abbastanza veloci questa è una
storia ambientata in sudan
come vedete linguaggi molto diversi tra
di loro ora
ancora vignette personaggi utilizzati
come car per karcher design
poi l'ultima e speriamo una delle ultime
esperienze con una casa editrice
canadese questi due signori lui è stato
candidato al premio oscar diversi anni
fa come l'animatore per un suo
cortometraggio lei invece una
sceneggiatrice di origine creola abbiamo
realizzato una storia appunto su un
personaggio haitiano una sola trisavole
abbastanza bella come sarà molto forte
sono alcuni disegni vado veloce
beh diciamo siamo tornati a punto e
daccapo confusione è tanta
magari un po di meno insomma perché
avevo il tempo qualche cosa nell'interno
il di linguaggio sperimentazione ha
portato a far diradare tutte queste
nuove una cosa ho capito sicuramente
bisogna all'interno del fumetto oppure
perseguire un proprio sogno bisogna
essere intanto corazzati come il dottor
destino forti come la cosa elastici
mentalmente fisicamente come mister
fantastic problematici ma questo è
indubbio insomma come l'uomo ragno po
arrabbiati come paperino però
simpaticissimi magari ci si riesce
astuti come topolino volte anche
antipatici allora a quel punto pieni di
risorse come braccio di ferro magici
come mandrake sognatori come il nemo o
ladri di idee naturalmente come i
bassotti di dati come proprio roga non
ha vari maicon gli altri perone affamati
non tanto come si di jobs preferisco
volto
il braccio di ferro e come ciccio di
nonna papera lirici come come snoopy xco
fatevi infine teneri commerciali bravo
grazie
[Applauso]